foreign
[Music]
if you're using Pub sub and want to
learn some client Library best practices
then stay tuned hi I'm Chloe and in this
video I'll be sharing six useful
features to consider using when working
with Pub sub let's take a look
number one client Library language when
using Pub sub take into consideration
the client Library language you will
choose we recommend using the Java
client Library over python for
performance reasons check out the link
in the description to dive deeper into
our blog post on testing Cloud Pub sub
clients to maximize streaming
performance to see some useful graphs
and data comparing Cloud Pub sub
performance by language number two reuse
publisher
reuse the same publisher client instead
of recreating new publisher clients to
avoid cold start problems the first
publish request takes longer than
subsequent requests
number three flow control
[Music]
consider setting flow control on the
publisher if your published requests are
timing out often
with high latency subscribers you may
need to decrease their flow control
settings to process fewer messages at
any given time number four always update
be sure to stay up to date with client
Library versions newer client Library
versions may contain fixes for critical
issues or are likely required to use
some new features check out our
documentation for all the latest info on
Pub Subs updates and features number
five use node async
in node.js all operations should be
async so the recommended mode of
operation is to use subscription dot on
to receive messages and
topic.publishmessage or topic.flow
controlled if publisher side flow
control is desired since many methods in
node.js allow for callbacks or promise
slash async based usage prefer the
latter this will help performance number
six lease management
looking to modify or extend your message
acknowledgment deadlines you can use
modacs to modify and extend message
acknowledgment deadlines
we recommend streaming poll over poll in
the libraries as libraries manage modacs
there you have it six useful features to
consider using working with Pub sub take
a look at our Pub sub documentation for
even more tips and tricks and check the
description below for links to
additional information as well as
step-by-step guides on the tools
discussed in this video
[Music]
foreign